now that we are familiar with Euler's
method let's do an exercise the tests
are mathematical understanding of it or
at least the the process of using it so
this is considered the differential
equation the derivative of Y with
respect to X is equal to 3x minus 2 I
let Y is equal to G of X be a solution
to the differential equation with the
initial condition G of 0 is equal to K
where K is constant Oilers method
starting at x equals 0 with the step
size of 1 gives the approximation the G
of 2 is approximately 4.5 find the value
of K so once again this is saying hey
look we're going to start with this
initial condition when X is equal to 0 Y
is equal to K we're going to we're going
to use Euler's method with the step size
of 1 so we're essentially going to use
we're going to step once from 0 to 1 and
then again from 1 to 2 and then that
approximation is going to give us 4.5
and so given that we started at K we
should be able to figure out what K was
to get us to G of 2 being approximated
as 4.5 so with that I encourage you to
pause the video and try to figure this
out on your own I am assuming you have
tried to figure this out on your own now
we can do it together and I'll do the
same thing that we did in the first
video on Euler's method I'll make a
little table here so let me make a
little table I can draw a straighter
line than that
that's only marginally straighter but
it'll get the job done so let's make
this column X let's I'm going to give
myself some space for Y I'm going to do
some calculation here Y and then a dy dy
DX now we can start at our initial
condition when X is equal 0 Y is equal
to K when X is equal to 0 Y is equal to
K and so what's our derivative going to
be at that point
well dy/dx is equal to 3x minus 2y so in
this case it's 3 times 0 minus 2 times K
which is just equal to negative 2 K and
so now we can increment one more step we
have a step size
different color we have a step size of
one so we're going to each in each step
we're going to increment in each step
we're going to increment X by one and so
we're now going to be at one now what's
our new y going to be well if we
increment X by one and our slope is
negative two K that means we're going to
increment Y by negative two K times one
or just negative two K so negative two K
so k plus negative two K is negative K
so our approximation using Euler's
method gets us the point 1 negative K
and then what is going to be our slope
starting at that point so one negative K
our slope is going to be three times our
X which is one minus two times our Y
which is negative K now and this is
equal to three plus two K 3 plus two K
and now we'll do another step of 1
because that's our step size another
whoops I'm going to get to two and this
is the one that we care about right
because we're trying to approximate G of
two so we have to say well what is our
approximate what is our approximation
give us for y when x is equal to two and
if we're going to have something
expressed in K but they're saying that's
going to be four point five and then so
we could use that to solve for K so
what's this going to be so if we
increment by one in X we should
increment our Y by one times three plus
two K which is just going to be so we're
going to increment by three plus two K 3
plus two K or negative K plus three plus
two K is just going to be three plus K 3
plus K and they're telling us that our
approximation gets that to be four point
five so three plus K is equal to four
point five so the K that we started with
must have been if we just subtract three
from both sides this is a decimal here
it must have been K must be equal to one
point five and you can verify that if
this initial condition right over here
if G of zero is equal to one point five
G of zero is equal to one point five
and you put 1.5 over here then over here
you would get 4.5 and we're done